podríamos tener un debate de cuáles las
células más interesantes del cuerpo pero
yo creo que fácilmente la neurona
estaría entre las cinco primeras y no
sólo porque la neurona en sí es
interesante sino que si tomamos en
cuenta que esencialmente constituye
nuestro cerebro y nuestro sistema
nervioso y que es responsable de los
pensamientos y de nuestros sentimientos
y tal vez de todos nuestros sentidos
yo creo que fácilmente estaría entre el
segundo o en el primer puesto primero
que nada te mostraré cómo se ve una
neurona de manera idealizada en general
y luego voy a hablar de cómo realiza su
función que es esencialmente la
comunicación esencialmente transmitir
señales a través de su largo dependiendo
de las señales que recibe
así que si yo fuera una neurona dibujada
déjame escojo un mejor color y déjame
cambio mi tamaño de brocha
vemos que tengo una neurona y se ve algo
así en el centro tiene su suma o péric
arión y enfrente de la zona déjame
dibujar un núcleo haré lo mejor que
pueda en el núcleo es justo como el
núcleo de cualquier célula
entonces la zona es considerada el
cuerpo de la neurona y luego la neurona
tiene estas pequeñas cositas saliendo de
ella que siguen ramificándose que siguen
ramificándose pueden parecerse a algo
como esto no quiero pasar mucho tiempo
solo dibujando la neurona pero
probablemente has visto dibujos como
estos antes y estas ramas fuera de la
zona de la neurona fuera de su cuerpo
son llamadas dendritas y pueden seguir
dividiéndose así haré un dibujo bastante
razonable de manera que gaste poco
tiempo haciéndolo
la última vendría
solo como esto entonces estas de aquí
estas son las dendritas y éstas tienden
a ser donde la neurona recibe su señal y
hablaremos más de qué significa recibir
y transmitir la señal en este vídeo y
probablemente en el siguiente vídeo
entonces es aquí donde ella recibe la
señal y entonces
dulces
esta de aquí
es la soma soma significa cuerpo este es
el cuerpo de la neurona y luego tenemos
luego tenemos algo normalmente visto
como la cola de la neurona es llamada
axón el axón la neurona puede ser
razonablemente ya saben unas células de
tamaño normal a pesar de que hay un gran
rango pero los acciones pueden ser
sumamente largos saben pueden ser cortos
algunas veces el cerebro puede tener
acciones muy cortos pero puedes tener
acciones que llegan a la columna
vertebral o que van a lo largo de una
costilla o si yo fuera un dinosaurio
iría a través de una costilla de
dinosaurio por lo que los axones pueden
en realidad estirarse varios pies no
todos los acciones son de varios pies
pero no pueden ser
y aquí es en verdad donde la señal
consigue viajar mucha distancia así que
déjame dibujar el acción así que la
acción se ve algo así y al final termina
con la terminal de la acción dónde
pueden conectar otras dos dendritas o
tal vez otros dos tipos de tejido
músculo si el objetivo de esta neurona
es decirle al músculo que haga algo así
que al final de la acción
tenemos la terminal de la acción justo
allí daré lo mejor que pueda para
dibujarla ahí está deja la etiqueta
entonces este es el axón esta es la
terminal del exxon y para algunas veces
escucharás la palabra del punto en el
que la soma o el cuerpo de la neurona se
conecta con el axón nos referimos a él
como el cono axón y ccoo podemos ver que
es como un bulto que empieza a formar el
axón entonces es el cono axón y ccoo
hablaremos de cómo cómo viajan los
impulsos una gran parte permitirá que
viajen eficientemente eficientemente
están estas células aisladas alrededor
del axón estas células aisladas
alrededor del axón
vamos a hablar de ellas en detalle y de
cómo trabajan realmente pero es bueno
tener la estructura anatómica primero
entonces estas se llaman células de
schwann y están cubriendo y ellas
componen la vaina de mielina entonces
esta cubierta esta insolación a
diferentes intervalos a lo largo de la
acción es llamada la vaina de mielina
entonces las células de schwann
constituyen la vaina de mielina
entonces estas son células de schwann o
vainas de mielina o vainas de mielina y
luego estos espacios entre la vaina de
mielina sólo para que tengamos toda la
terminología para que sepamos la
anatomía entera de la neurona estos se
llaman los nodos de ramier y creo que
son llamados debido a ranbir tal vez él
fue el amigo que vio que tenían este
espacio aquí donde no tienen vainas de
mielina por lo que estos son los nodos
de rabia
de tal manera que la idea general como
mencioné es que obtienes una señal y
luego estas señales transformada las
señales pueden sumarse entonces tienes
una señal ahí otra señal ahí tal que es
una señal más grande ahí y luego los
efectos combinados de estas señales se
suman y viajan al cono axón y ccoo y si
son lo suficientemente grandes si son lo
suficientemente grandes provocan un
potencial real en los exones lo que
ocasionará que la señal viaje hasta los
límites de la acción y luego aquí puede
conectarse díaz sinapsis a otras
benditas o músculos vamos a hablar más
acerca de las sinapsis y esos pueden
ayudar a provocar otras cosas vamos sólo
a decir qué es lo que está activando
estas cosas de aquí pues esto puede ser
el final de terminal de otros acciones
de neurona como en el cerebro ésta puede
ser un tipo de neurona sensorial ésta
puede estar pensando en algún lado ya
sabes una molécula de sal de alguna
manera puede activarla o molécula de
azúcar o esto puede ser un gran bonche
de diferentes cosas